I like to talk to you guys now about the different
steps that are required to complete the robotic
vision project. Let's take a look now what
the steps are.
So the first week which you are currently
doing now is the project introduction. So
in this week we're going to learn about what
the project is and see what the final output
should be. So what is actually required from
the project. You need to download the robotic
vision worksheet and print it off. So it's
in a pdf format and it's in an A2. So you
can print off an A4 and join 4x4 sheet together
to get the full A2 work sheet.
The last thing that you have to do is to make
sure that all the software of your computer
is configured including MATLAB and all the
toolboxes so the robotic vision tool box will
need to be installed. If you're following
the course then this should already been completed.
The next week is called getting an image.
So the first you need to do is to take a photo
of the work sheet using a particular camera
you have, so that can be a mobile phone camera,
a compact camera or a webcam.
So just a camera to take a photo of the worksheet.
The next step is that we're going to get that
photo and then load the photo image into MATLAB.
The final thing for that week is to make sure
that you guys understand what MATLAB functions
look like and how they work. So this whole
project is going to be broken down into a
series of MATLAB functions that we're going
to join together at the end.
Now just note that these functions are going
to be quite small so there is going to be
less than a hundred lines of code. If you're
writing functions that are more than a hundred
lines of code, then you really need to stop
and rethink your approach because your algorithm
is getting much too large for this particular
project.
The next week is week 3 and that's color segmentation.
So for this week we will be writing a MATLAB
function and the output for that function
will be a binary image of a particular color
that we specify. So we'll be generating a
binary image for the red color space, green
color space and blue color space.
We'll also be experimenting with gamma correction
and chromaticity coordinates so these two
methods will allow us to get better binary
image outputs from the MATLAB function when
we do the color segmentation.
Week 4 is called shape and size. So for this
week we'll be writing another MATLAB function
that classifies the 2D objects that exist
on our work sheet in terms of a shape. So
the shape can be either a square, circle or
a triangle and a size with the size can be
either small or large.
And in this week we'll be learning about blobs
in image processing and their different properties.
So we're going to be getting a blob from our
binary image and then we'll see that particular
property and then try and classify in terms
of other shape and size.
After that comes week 5 which is homography.
Now in this week we're going to be writing
two different functions. The first MATLAB
function that we'll be writing will allow
us to find the blue calibration circles on
our work sheets. So there are nine calibration
circles and this function will identify the
pixel positions of the calibration circles on the page.
The next function that we'll write will generate
a homography matrix. So we will take the position
of the calibration circles, will also measure
the x and y Cartesian position of the circles.
And then with these two different points,
we then generate a homography matrix.
And the final thing we'll learn is why homography
matrices are useful and how they can fail
with different sets of points.
Last week is week 6, for weeks 1 through 6
of the complete vision system and in this
week we'll be combining all the previous week's
functions that was written. Everything that
was done will be rolled into a MATLAB script
and that would generate the output for our
project. We'll identify the position of all the 2D objects and print that out into the MATLAB work space.
Also this week, we'll investigate some interesting
ways we can represent the output to the 2D
object position data and how we can interact,
how users can interact with this data. So
that is week 1 through 6 for the robotic vision
project.
And the final week, which is optional, is
called integration with the robot. So in this
week, we're going to take the 2D position
output from the robot vision project and then
feed that into the input of a robotic arm
system. So that will allow us to get our robotic
arm system and then move it or actuate it
to a 2D object on our work sheet page.
So those are the full weeks of the robotic
vision projects. I hope you'll join me in
completing this project.